uh let's talk about miners and
what's going on they seem to be just
selling every bitcoin in their uh in
their wallets miners are selling at a
rapid pace they sold about 14 000
bitcoin in a single day
equal to over 300 million dollars and
miners just across the board public
miners especially have been dumping
bitcoin do you know how uh miners and
the pressure they're under when the
price goes down do you understand how
that works
a little bit could you explain it in a
little more detail so
if you think of miners right the whole
name of the game uh for a miner is to go
find the lowest cost power possible
go find machines for as low as possible
those are their input costs essentially
raise the cost of the machine cost of
the energy
they then plug them in and they mine
bitcoin that bitcoin usually is produced
or mined
at a cost to them that is lower than the
current price so we'll use an easy
example if bitcoin was trading at forty
thousand dollars miners may mine it at
ten thousand dollar cost to them so they
spend ten thousand dollars for everyone
bitcoin they might i'm over generalized
numbers
if
bitcoin is trading at forty thousand
dollars and you it only cost you ten
thousand dollars that's pretty good
thirty thousand dollars worth of profit
for every bitcoin you mine
now that is for the absolute best miners
in the world those with the lowest cost
power or access to the best machines at
the best price
there are some miners specifically
usually the residential miners you know
individuals
they may have a higher cost of power
sometimes let's call it four times
higher
so instead of paying three cents a
kilowatt hour maybe they're paying 12.
and so in that situation it costs you
forty thousand dollars to mine one
bitcoin that equals forty thousand
dollars
well the problem becomes if bitcoin's
price drops
now all of a sudden you're spending
forty thousand dollars to mine a bitcoin
that let's say now is trading at thirty
thousand dollars so what do you do
either you continue to mine bitcoin at a
loss or you shut off your machine
now because it's residential they don't
have a lot of miners so what do they do
they shut off not a big deal to the
network
but if the price continues to fall and
now it's trading at 20 000 those miners
with the lowest cost power and the best
priced machines they can continue to
mine because they have a ten thousand
dollar production cost for a bitcoin
that's trading at twenty thousand
dollars
but one of the challenges is that these
miners their expenses are denominated in
dollars
so as an example
let's say that you were able to mine one
million dollars worth of bitcoin per
month when bitcoin was at forty thousand
dollars and your expenses were seven
hundred thousand dollars a month you had
a three hundred thousand dollar profit
and all was good in the world
if now all of a sudden bitcoin's price
goes from forty thousand to twenty
thousand you went from making a million
dollars in revenue to five hundred
thousand in revenue well if you're
making five hundred thousand dollars in
revenue and your expenses which are
denominated in dollars is still seven
hundred thousand
you now are unprofitable so what do you
do
what many of the miners will do is they
will sell bitcoin that they've been
accumulating on their balance sheets to
be able to raise cash so that they can
pay one their expenses
and two is to ensure that regardless of
how low bitcoin's price goes they won't
go bankrupt they won't go out of
business
and so naturally as the price falls some
portion of miners become for sellers
because they've got to raise cash in the
balance sheet
now one argument is that this is a
positive thing because the miners are
being able to protect themselves another
argument is no the miners should
actually uh ever do everything possible
in their power to never sell the bitcoin
whole point of mining is if you can mine
bitcoin even if it's at a profit today
and hold it for a really long period of
time it's supposed to go up in value
and so naturally what you're seeing is
miners as the price fell down in june
and what broke 20 thousand dollars lots
of miners were selling they've continued
to sell because they need cash
yeah but when you look at it uh the big
guys obviously are hoping and trying to
weather the storm it seems like right
like they're the ones selling off
bitcoin they're the ones that have the
most machines have the cheapest power
all that stuff but when you look at
retail what should the average person do
should they just turn off their machine
if if they're losing money every single
day the machine's on like that's the
ultimate question i think well there's
uh some people who are not economic
actors in mining some of you they just
like the idea of mining and they're
gonna do it regardless they feel like
they're contributing to the network
right there's some people who say uh i
don't care if i lose a little bit of
money now i already have a sunk cost of
uh the machine i already spent money on
the machine the second thing is uh i
just tapped into the electricity in my
house or i'm doing my garage or
something so yes i'm paying you know 12
13 14 cents a kilowatt hour but
whatever it's not like i have like a
special agreement you know or whatever
it's just my electrical costs at my
house uh and then oh i'm going to just
mine the bitcoin and if i hold it for
long enough then eventually the bitcoin
be worth more than it is today and so
yes i'm losing money in the short term
but i already bought the machines like i
should just keep mining and then there
are the people who are the economic
actors who say like why am i mining
bitcoin out of laws uh if i'm going to
deploy more dollars uh then i should
just go buy bitcoin rather than buy more
mining equipment how much of this is
energy cost for bitcoin price
so for those uh that are unaware um
those are two main components there is
one a third thing that is important here
so you have the energy cost which is
fixed right most people don't uh go to
their power provider and say hey bitcoin
was at 40 000 i was paying five cents a
kilowatt hour uh it dropped to 20. i
need i'm gonna have to have you hooked
me up with two and a half cents right
it's just like you pay five uh five
cents this is why miners are obsessed
with how do you get the lowest cost
power because one it uh optimizes your
profitability but two it acts as
protection when bitcoin's price turns
down second thing is obviously bitcoin's
price
but the third thing is the difficulty
adjustment so if you go back to may of
2021
when about 65 of all hash rate was in
china china specifically one province
said hey get the hell out of here we're
serious this time and about 50 of all
hash rate uh on the bitcoin network left
and so they unplugged their machines and
moved them elsewhere sometimes they
didn't actually go plug them in anywhere
else other times they move them and they
ended up plugging them in
when we had a 50 drop in the hash rate
because of that china ban
what we saw was the difficulty
adjustment went down meaning that if
there's a hundred people trying to mine
right then the difficulty adjustment
let's just say is kind of flat if all of
a sudden there was 150 people trying to
mine the difficulty adjustment would go
up because it's trying to make it more
difficult for any one miner to win right
there's more competition
if all of a sudden we went from 100
miners down to 50
the difficulty adjustment would adjust
downward because it wants to make it
easier for those 50 to go ahead and do
it now why would you do that
if it's easier what does that act next
is an incentive
the easier it is to mine the more people
who want to mine so it brings back a ton
of miners if all of a sudden there's
tons and tons of miners and it's really
difficult the next incremental miner it
isn't as attractive to them right or
it's less attractive than it was before
all those miners showed up so naturally
that difficulty adjustment acts as
almost like a regulator right or like a
balancer in terms of always ensuring
that as miners shut off their machines
because the price is going down the
difficulty adjustment moves downward as
well to ensure that miners always want
to come onto the network and so that
balancing mechanism is what prevents
this idea of like a mining death spiral
which there is an idea of like well if
you have miners
who all of a sudden flip to losing money
on each bitcoin they would shut their
machines off so the network would grow
less and less secure and then they would
need to sell their bitcoin in order to
be able to uh
fund you know expenses and that would
then push the price further which would
cause more miners to shut down which
would cause them to sell more bitcoin
and like you'd get in this death spiral
on the way down
the difficulty adjustment is what helps
to prevent that from actually occurring
how do you think about um is the
ultimate goal just as many miners on the
network as possible or does it difficult
to get too high to where it's like not
economically sound for so many retail
miners that like the big boys are
playing the whole space and there's no
there's no room for any like retail
miners there's a relationship between
price and hash rate right hash rate is
the measurement of how much uh how many
miners how many computing powers on the
network um some people will say hash
rate leads price some people say price
leads hash rate chicken or egg right
depending on who you talk to uh but i do
think that there's a very important part
of the bitcoin network is ultimately
secured by the miners now the nodes
technically are validating the
transactions
and so we want as many miners as
possible because that means that the
network is more secure now one of the
things that uh
has occurred is obviously 65 of the hash
rate was in china now all of a sudden
about 10 percent or so is the latest
estimation i saw 10 percent of all hash
rate globally is in texas and about 30
to 35 percent of all hash rate uh
globally is in the united states now 35
let's call it is better than 65 percent
in any one country but i think we have
to uh be careful that we don't over
rotate from 65 in china to 65 in the
united states either like we actually
want a a truly decentralized distributed
network where uh folks feel like uh
there there is no ability for one
country to you know unilaterally act to
shut down uh miners all right what are
your thoughts on like obviously a bunch
of retail miners have loans it seems
like to pay for these machines and then
payments are recurring every single
month they still have to pay those those
are the fixed costs like how should
someone think about okay i have a loan
but i'm still mining at a loss i have
conviction but i still don't know when
that will happen like what's the time
frame of all that like how should i
think about that yeah um it's kind of
like leverage right yeah
it's almost worse than leverage which is
uh
in leverage you have the ability to
liquidate the asset right like if i you
know using an easy example if i borrow a
hundred thousand dollars to buy bitcoin
and uh i posted 200 000 as collateral
i basically can weather you know 30 40
50 draw down before i would get
liquidated but if at any point i'm like
oh [ __ ] i think the bitcoin price is
going down i can just with the click of
a button sell the bitcoin pay off the
the leverage or the loan uh and i still
have some bitcoin left but there's a 24
7 365 highly liquid market that i can do
that immediately right
if instead i basically took a loan uh
and i didn't go buy bitcoin with it i
bought mining equipment and i want to
quote liquidate
to be able to pay off the loan
uh because the price is dropping
it's not as easy it's not a 24 7 365
highly liquid market where i can just
press a button and bam the miners are
sold
and so i think that ends up being one of
the uh the difficulties there now if
you're a large-scale miner you've got a
big balance sheet you've got access to
capital markets and you're able to kind
of in a sophisticated way get access to
debt to be able to finance this stuff
sure there's plenty of people who will
go do that right debt is a component of
uh businesses all in every industry
yeah i agree and we've actually seen the
cost of miners has dropped obviously in
correlation with price going down miners
getting off the network they're selling
their machines they don't know what to
do with them i don't know what it is now
it used to be uh like the s9s that was
when i uh when i first started uh mining
uh that was um
that was the the best piece of equipment
at the time uh now uh pretty much no one
uses those um
they essentially would price them based
on what they thought uh it would take
nine months or so to mine back your
money okay so they would say like okay
cool if you use this machine and you
mine for nine months you'll make uh 3
200
so then they would sell it for 3 200
right it and then i think at some point
it went from nine to maybe 12 months or
whatever but basically it was like we
want to price the equipment so that you
can buy it if you plug it in today and
you mine for nine to 12 months you'll
get your money back
and so
naturally if the price of bitcoin goes
down well they have to drop the price of
the miners right it's also a function of
the price of bitcoin goes down people
are less excited so there's less demand
for mining equipment if price goes up
though
there's bananas right there there was uh
uh nines um i'll probably mess up the
numbers but i think it was like twelve
hundred dollars maybe it was like the
average price and at one point people
were buying s9s for like three four
thousand dollars uh during the 2017 bull
market
gotcha yeah bringing up a uh
bringing up a chart now um all right
whatever uh can you talk about the minor
capitulation like i've seen that all
over twitter obviously that's what we
were talking about yeah it's basically
miners saying uh yo it's over like i
gotta shut off my machines i gotta sell
my bitcoin because i have dollar
denominated uh expenses um and so the
whole idea of minor capitulation is
basically uh similar to what we saw uh
on the trading side is at some point
there had to be liquidations right there
had to be people like
damn it's it's over it's done right um
and so naturally what you get in those
situations um is on the minor side same
thing you get people shutting down their
equipment you get them selling their
assets uh and it's either because
they're for sellers which is the
equivalent of being liquidated if you
had like leverage or something uh or two
is psychologically uh they think it's
over now
i don't think we're getting a lot of
psychological capitulation right
actually it's the exact opposite people
are like damn this is annoying but like
they have long-term conviction in the
asset and in the market uh i do think
that there's a lot of force selling so
in june if you remember bitcoin's price
drew all the way down to 17 500 uh
significantly below the realized price
on chain uh and a number of other
metrics was the first time in bitcoin's
history that uh bitcoin had dipped below
a previous all-time high um after a bull
run
and so there's a lot of miners just a
lot of pressure and so what were they
doing that's where you saw the the
miners selling pretty much from you know
june 1st till today uh they're just for
sellers now that we talked about retail
i want to talk about like the big boys
right so
they sold a lot of bitcoin in july verse
june they sold about 23 of their
holdings public miners does that worry
you at all
that they're selling so much that
they're selling 23 of the overall
holdings it's better than selling 50
right
again what they're trying to do is
they're trying to play a game of how
much do we have to sell but if you were
to go ask them like hey wave a magic
wand do you want to sell any bitcoin
they'd say no
right and so uh yeah look at these
numbers here bitcoin sold in june the
top five bitcoin sellers in may and june
in public minors core scientific between
may and june has sold 9900 bitcoin right
just under 10 000. uh bit farms uh
northern data argo and clean spark have
sold between you know call it 538 and
300 bitcoin
and so
when you look at this uh in many cases
uh the selling in may
was much smaller than the selling in
june
why are the percentage in june versus
may so high it's because they were for
sellers right now for sellers doesn't
mean uh that like the business is bad or
it's gonna go out of business or
whatever it just means that they uh are
having to sell bitcoin to make sure that
they have a strong enough balance sheet
that they can uh fulfill their us dollar
denominated uh obligations uh and they
want to make sure that they're going to
survive because the name of the game in
bear markets is to survive
and the name of the game in mining is to
mine as much bitcoin as possible and
never sell it
right those are like the two strategies
that you'll see people uh kind of talk
about who've been around for a while uh
when you see miners selling it just
means that they're selling because they
have to not because they want to from in
most cases
yeah and then how do you think about the
transaction fees that they're receiving
right so having more machines on is good
because you're getting more you're more
money right but you could be operating
at that loss so like
should they think about plugging in more
machines if they really have that much
conviction right like none of this
financial advice but yeah most miners i
think um you know look they do inside of
a block you basically get uh the mining
reward there's some transaction fees as
well the uh the idea is uh 2140 uh all
the bitcoin will be mined uh and then
the network will be sustainable on
transaction fees at that point there's
plenty of people who argue that are
critics that say no that's not possible
or whatever
when you begin to look at uh what miners
are doing i don't know very many miners
who are like yo let's go set up more
miners because we're gonna get more
transaction fees right the way they look
at it is uh that bitcoin reward uh is
gonna end up being uh the the big
incentive if you will and then on top of
uh the bitcoin uh kind of block subsidy
uh you also see miners who say to
themselves uh how do i manage my balance
sheet i know what my dollar denominated
obligations are if i have to mine at a
loss and i got a really really big
balance sheet and i've got deep
conviction in bitcoin and i'm basically
taking a directional bet that you know
within 12 months it'll recover then
maybe i go plug them in but if i don't
have a big balance sheet if i'm not
coming at this from a position of
strength
maybe i don't go plug in new machines
maybe i don't put in that new order
because i need to be able to ensure i'm
gonna get to the other side like rule
number one is survive rule number two is
get as much bitcoin as possible but you
don't focus on number two if you're not
sure you're gonna actually fulfill rule
number one of make sure you survive